according to legend 30 years ago Atari
buried truckloads of videogames in this
desert now these guys want to try to dig
them up wired is here first on the scene
we're going to talk to you
Zach pen who's directing a documentary
about the Atari dig and we're gonna see
what is actually been buried underneath
the sand here for the last 30 years so
thank you again for having us here to
the the pre dig dig it's not Moneo
groundbreaking my pleasure welcome to my
dump yes thank you so what what are what
are they doing today what s happened
today before the big game can happen
tomorrow
well today what we need to do is up you
know where we think everything is buried
is about 22 feet underground okay
theoretically by the end of today we
will reach the so-called concrete cap
that was poured over the games you know
which like everything in this story I
don't have any confirmation of now what
are the what is the danger that they
might just hit something that they're
like whoa this is too hazardous we can't
dig through this everybody go home so
what are the odds what are the odds or I
mean yeah exactly
you know I really don't know in fact the
guy who knows is over there Joe I'm not
sure I think it's a possibility we've
definitely hit some bumps in the road
that's 300 acres are out of here over 30
years worth of garbage or we've kind of
pinned it down to a certain point and we
had to do that and convince the entire
department we
we had the location because they will
not let you turn a little dump into
Swiss cheese you're not gonna just go
let you poke holes too you finally
figure it out so this is the first hole
and the only hole there either there or
not and so that's good the story's gonna
be done if we don't hit him that does it
for our coverage of today they are going
to continue to clear the 20 feet of
garbage off of these games and we are
going to come back tomorrow to see what
is finally buried underneath